who wears short shorts liam hemsworth  that's ooh here we go rolling up 27  year-old Aussie actor shared a lot of  himself on Instagram Monday morning and  we mean a lot the Hunger Games star  posted a series of shots wearing very  little clothing with the caption here's  two ice baths and flexing in tiny shorts  the pics showcased to Liam's chiseled  ABS toned muscles and well just about  everything else the heartthrob also  shared this shot with his fiance Miley  Cyrus writing my little angel and I as  for Liam's little angel she showed off  her new sunflower tattoo on Sunday a  symbol for her devotion to being a vegan  she captioned the snap shot vegan for  life and the love is strong between  Miley and her man in 2013 the 24 year  old gushed over Liam to ET someone asked  me today what my celebrity crush was and  I really don't think there's anyone  hotter that's like making films  you